행렬의 가중 평균, 즉 p×ρ + (1-p)×σ예요. 이건 사실
ρ와 σ가 밀도 행렬이 아니라 확률 상태를 나타내는 확률 벡터인 경우와 완전히 유사해요.
그러니까 이건 충격적이거나 신비한 게 아니라, 오히려 확률 이론에서
익숙한 것이에요. 우리는 확률을 계산하고 고전적인 무작위 선택을 생각할 때 항상 이런 종류의 평균을 사용해요.
그리고 요점은, 이게 밀도 행렬에도 작동한다는 거예요. 하지만 양자 상태 벡터에는 작동하지 않아요.
즉, 두 양자 상태 벡터를 이런 식으로 평균해서 유효한 양자 상태 벡터를 얻으려고 할 수는 없어요.
시도하면 보통 유클리드 노름이 1이 아닌 벡터를 얻게 돼요. 반면 밀도 행렬의 경우, 이런 가중 평균은 항상
유효한 밀도 행렬이 되고, 더 중요하게는 얻은 밀도 행렬이 그 무작위 선택을 의미 있는 방식으로 나타내요.
이건 두 가지 이상의 대안이 있는 무작위 선택으로 일반화돼요.
특히, m개의 가능한 밀도 행렬과 각 밀도 행렬에 하나씩 대응되는 m개의 원소를 가진 확률 벡터가 있고,
시스템이 각 가능한 상태에 해당하는 확률로 준비된다면,
그 밀도 행렬들의 가중 평균이 시스템의 결과 상태를 설명해요. 그런데 밀도 행렬의
볼록 조합이라고 할 때, 이게 그 의미예요. 볼록 조합은 단순히 계수가 확률 벡터를 이루는
선형 결합이에요. 이건 항상 밀도
행렬이 돼요. 수학적 용어로 간결하게 표현하면, 주어진 시스템에 해당하는 모든 밀도 행렬의 집합은
볼록 집합이에요. 예를 들어 m개의 양자 상태
벡터 ψ₀부터 ψₘ₋₁까지, 그리고 이들을 합하면 확률 벡터가 되는 확률 p₀부터 pₘ₋₁까지 있고,
시스템이 각 k에 대해 확률 pₖ로 상태 ψₖ에 준비된다면,
시스템의 결과 상태는 화면에 나타난 밀도 행렬로 설명돼요. 특히, 양자 상태
벡터 자체를 평균하는 게 아니라, 그에 해당하는 밀도 행렬들을 평균하는 거예요.
일반적으로 이런 상태는 단일 양자 상태 벡터로 표현되지 않아요.
모든 양자 상태 벡터가 전역 위상까지 동치이거나, 확률 중 하나를 제외한 나머지가 모두 0인 것처럼 무언가 사소한 일이 일어나지 않는 한요.
이런 과정에서 순수 양자 상태를 얻는 게 아니라, 어떤 내재적 불확실성이 포함된
혼합 양자 상태라고 하는 것을 얻어요. 간단한 예시를 살펴볼게요.
qubit이 있고 확률 1/2로 0 상태에 준비되고, 그렇지 않으면
플러스 상태에 준비된다고 가정해 볼게요. 제가 설명한 대로 평균을 내서 얻는 밀도 행렬이 여기 있어요.
두 가능한 상태에 해당하는 밀도 행렬을 계산하고, 해당 확률을 곱하고 더하면 돼요.
얻는 건 실제로 밀도 행렬이에요. 에르미트이고, 트레이스가 1이에요.
이 행렬의 고유값을 계산하면 두 양수 실수를 얻게 되는데, 지금쯤 익숙한 두 숫자일 거예요.
cos²(π/8)과 sin²(π/8), 즉 약 0.85와
0.15예요. 이 상태의 단일 양자 상태 벡터 표현은 없어요. 순수 상태가 아니에요. 다음으로 단일 qubit의 양자 상태를 나타내는 특정 밀도 행렬,
즉 완전히 혼합된 상태를 살펴볼게요.
이 상태는 자주 나타나기 때문에 이름을 갖는 게 좋고, 밀도 행렬의 중요한 특징을 보여주는 좋은 예시이기도 해요.
사실 모든 시스템에 대해 유사하게 정의된 완전히 혼합된 상태가 있지만,
지금은 단순하게 단일 qubit에 대한 이 상태에 집중할게요.
qubit의 상태를 각각 확률 1/2로 0 상태 또는 1 상태로 무작위로 설정한다고 가정해 볼게요.
균일한 무작위 비트와 비슷해요. 일반적인 방법으로 이 상태의 밀도 행렬 표현을 계산할 수 있어요.
두 상태의 밀도 행렬 표현의 평균을 취하면 돼요. 행렬 형태로 어떻게 되는지 보면,
얻는 건 2로 나눈 항등 행렬이에요.
이 상태를 완전히 혼합된 상태라고 하고, 기본적으로 qubit에 대한 완전한 또는 최대의
불확실성을 나타내요. 마치 균일한 확률 벡터가 고전적 확률 설정에서 최대 불확실성을 나타내는 것처럼요.
일반적으로 임의의 시스템에서 완전히 혼합된 상태는 표준 기저 상태를 균일하게 선택해서 얻는 상태이고,
밀도 행렬 표현은 차원, 즉 그 시스템의 고전적 상태의 수로 나눈
항등 행렬이 돼요. 지금 이건 단순한 용어이지만, 설정을 약간 바꾸면 밀도 행렬의 중요한 특징을 볼 수 있어요.
특히, 절차를 바꿔서 0과 1 표준 기저 상태 대신
플러스와 마이너스 상태로 대체한다고 가정해 볼게요. 이번에는 화면에 나타난
수식에서 시작하지만, 산술 과정을 거치면 정확히 같은
밀도 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 2로 나눈 항등 행렬이에요. 따라서 이전과 같은 상태,
즉 완전히 혼합된 상태예요. 이건 사람들이 말하듯이 버그가 아닌 기능이에요.
두 절차는 사실 다르지만, 결과로 얻은 qubit만 가지고 있다면 물리적으로 구별할 방법이 없어요.
통계적인 의미에서도 마찬가지예요. 예를 들어, 첫 번째 절차 수행 후 이 qubit에 표준 기저 측정을 수행하면
당연히 확률 1/2로 결과 0을, 확률 1/2로 결과 1을 얻게 돼요. 그런데 두 번째 절차에서도
정확히 같은 결과 확률을 얻게 돼요. 그리고 qubit 자체만 테스트한다고 가정하면,
다른 어떤 테스트를 고안하더라도 마찬가지예요. 일반적으로 밀도 행렬은 시스템이 어떻게 준비되었는지를 설명하지 않아요.
단지 그 시스템에 무언가를 할 경우 앞으로 무슨 일이 일어날지만 알려줘요. 연산을 수행하든
측정을 수행하든 마찬가지예요. 실제로 밀도 행렬은 이 점에서 완벽해요.
두 가지 다른 대안이 같은 밀도 행렬을 만들어낸다면, 통계적으로도
구별할 수 없어요. 하지만 두 밀도 행렬이 다르다면, 반드시 구별할 방법이 있어요.
결정적으로는 아닐 수도 있지만, 통계적인 의미에서는요. 양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화를 사용할 때